es ist eine spannende und außerdem auch
wichtige premiere denn es handelt sich
tatsächlich um die erste sauerstoff
gewinnung auf einem fremden planeten in
der geschichte der raumfahrt dem mars
rover person wir uns ist es gelungen
sauerstoff aus der mars atmosphäre zu
gewinnen und den nasa fachleuten geht es
hierbei nicht nur und die atemluft für
zukünftige crewmitglieder der mars
mission klicks um science and future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen vielen dank
für den themenvorschlag von jakob binde
über unsere klicks um science and future
telegramm gruppe bekommen haben
jetzt steht es also fest das experiment
moxie der nasa ist gelungen der
mars-rover perso wir uns hat es
geschafft sauerstoff aus der mars
atmosphäre zu extrahieren ein kleiner
kasten ist also in der lage mit hilfe
von strom und hitze das kohlendioxid der
mars atmosphäre zu spalten und
sauerstoff zu gewinnen ein echter
meilenstein für die nasa und einen
wirklich entscheidender erfolg denn für
ein leben auf dem mars ist sauerstoff
offensichtlich unabdingbar
dafür gibt es zwei möglichkeiten der
sauerstoff muss entweder zum roten
planeten hin transportiert werden oder
eben direkt vor ort produziert werden
und nicht nur tesla chef elon musk
wünscht sich dass auch die nasa arbeitet
mit hochdruck daran dass wir menschen
möglicherweise irgendwann einmal
multiplayer tag also auch mehreren
planeten leben können ihre maske ist
jedenfalls davon überzeugt dass wir
menschen eines tages den mars besiedeln
werden
seiner meinung nach kann lediglich eine
autarke statt auf dem roten planeten das
fortbestehen der menschheit sichern
und tatsächlich der mars es aus
verschiedenen gründen ein planet auf dem
man sich leben sondern es theoretisch
vorstellen kann beispielsweise hat er
zumindest eine dünne atmosphäre die vor
kosmischer strahlung schützt zum anderen
sind die temperaturen dort einigermaßen
hinnehmbar
und es gibt genügend sonnenlicht das man
nutzen könnte außerdem ist der tag und
nachtrhythmus auf dem mars dem der erde
relativ ähnlich einen tag dort dauert
nämlich 24 stunden 39 minuten und 35
sekunden
dennoch gibt es natürlich auch einige
hürden unter anderem die frage wie
können wir menschen auf dem roten
planeten wasser nahrung und eben
sauerstoff produzieren das nase
experiment maxi hat jetzt gezeigt dass
eine sauerstoff produktion vor ort
möglich ist damit steht fest dass die
idee funktioniert und der plan aufgeht
und dabei geht es der nasa nicht nur um
die atemluft für die crew mitglieder der
künftigen missionen auf dem roten
planeten dazu später noch mehrere der
mars-rover per sowie über uns hat mit
dieser erfolgsmeldung an seinem
bisherigen pioniertaten angeknüpft
das muss man wirklich mal so sagen
obwohl der nasa wurde ja erst ein paar
wochen auf dem roten planeten unterwegs
ist hat er schon für einige aha momente
gesorgt er bescherte uns zum einen ein
video das erstmals zeigt wie eine
landung auf dem mars aus sicht einer
raumsonde aussieht und dann legte er
nach und zeichnete mit seinem mikrofon
auf wie es klingt wenn er auf der
marsoberfläche unterwegs ist seinem
begleiter den maßen schrauber ingenuity
gelang dann der erste motorflug eines
menschengemachten gefährt auf einem
fremden planeten und jetzt ein weiterer
entscheidender meilenstein person wir
uns machte es jetzt zum ersten mal in
der geschichte der raumfahrt möglich
dass auf einem fremden planeten
sauerstoff aus der umgebung gewonnen
werden konnte konkret ist dies dem
kleinen kasten zu verdanken denen der
mars rover auf seiner instrumenten
plattform trägt der name des kastens
moxie und das steht für maas occident
inception resource utilization
experiment auf deutsch also etwa mars
experiment zur nutzung der möglichkeiten
vor ort
dieser kasten wieder auf der erde nur 18
kilo und auf dem mars die hälfte ist
dabei etwa so groß wie ein toaster oder
eine autobatterie aber er vollbringt
wirklich großes aktiviert wurde erstmals
am 20 april diesen jahres und jetzt ist
klar dass nase experiment ist ein voller
erfolg pro stunde konnte mox sie bei
seinem ersten test 5 gramm sauerstoff
erzeugen das wäre die menge an atemluft
die ein astronaut in zehn minuten
verbraucht hier ist also noch etwas luft
nach oben dennoch feiert die nasa diesen
erfolg sehr wenn das experiment belegt
das einen menschen gemachtes gerät
sauerstoff aus der umgebung eines
fremden planeten gewinnen kann doch wie
gelangen ist maxi sauerstoff aus der
sehr dünnen und kohlendioxid reichen
maßlos zu erzeugen
dazu sagt das instrument die luft ein
und komprimiert diese das gas besteht
tatsächlich aus rund 94 prozent co2 und
sucht dann stark erhitzt auf 800 grad so
wird es dann in einem behälter geleitet
in dem sich auch zwei elektroden
befinden und hier läuft dann eine
elektrolyse ab das kohlendioxid wird bei
diesem vorgang in kohlenmonoxid und eben
sauerstoff gespalten der sauerstoff
sammelt sich an der sogenannten kathode
und könnte dann hier als atem gas
genutzt werden
die west gase werden gefiltert und
ströme zurück in die marsatmosphäre
wirklich sehr vereinfacht gesagt
funktioniert das also wie eine art
künstlicher baum kohlendioxid geht rein
und sauerstoff kommt raus die maßlos
wird angesaugt unter druck gesetzt und
dann aufgespalten rauskommen sauerstoff
und kohlenmonoxid und nicht nur der
sauerstoff als ergebnis ist hier
gewünscht auch das kohlenmonoxid kann
gebraucht werden wird hier nämlich
wiederum sauerstoff zugesetzt könnte
dies als treibstoff einen rover oder
generator antreiben ein wichtiges
ergebnis für künftige mars mission also
dazu sagt der nasa forscher jim reuter
dies ist ein entscheidender erster
schritt zur umwandlung von kohlendioxid
zu sauerstoff auf dem mars die
ergebnisse dieser technologie
demonstration machen hoffnung für unser
ziel eines tages menschen auf den mars
zu sehen den fachleuten weltweit ist
klar um menschen auf dem mars mit
sauerstoff zu versorgen und ebenso auch
den treibstoff für den rückflug zu
sichern musste sauerstoff auf dem roten
planeten selbst gewonnen werden
sein transport von der erde zum mars
wäre zwar auch denkbar das wäre nicht
nur technisch super aufwendig sondern
vor allem extrem teuer
um das mal zu verdeutlichen das folgende
beispiel allein um eine rakete mit vier
personen an bord von der marsoberfläche
ins all zu bringen wären 25 tonnen
sauerstoff und 7 tonnen
raketentreibstoff notwendig da ist es
natürlich sehr viel wirtschaftlicher und
einfacher einen solchen sauerstoff
converter zu betreiben
das heißt also im klartext der auf dem
mars gewonnene sauerstoff ist nicht nur
wichtig um künftig menschen auf dem mars
das atmen zu ermöglichen sondern auch
für den
flug zur erde ein elementarer
bestandteil sind auch die rakete braucht
für die rückkehr zur erde eine menge
sauerstoff und der anteil an sauerstoff
den die raketen crew beim atmen
verbraucht ist dazu im vergleich
wirklich minimal
dazu sagt der wissenschaftler michael
hecht vom massachusetts institute of
technology
vier astronauten die ein jahr auf dem
mars verbringen wir brauchen zusammen
vielleicht eine tonne sauerstoff die
nasa fachleute planen das maxxi in der
kommenden zeit noch mindestens neun mal
versuchen soll sauerstoff aus der mars
atmosphäre zu ziehen
die nasa will in diesem kontext
beispielsweise ausprobieren zu welchen
tages und jahreszeiten das verfahren
besonders gut funktioniert die nasa
fachleute sind jedenfalls sehr zufrieden
mit den bisherigen ergebnissen und die
forscherin trudi courts sagt dazu maxi
ist nicht nur das erste instrument das
sauerstoff auf einem anderen planeten
gewinnt ist auch der erste vorreiter
einer technologie die ist künftigen
missionen erlauben wird elemente aus der
umwelt einer anderen welt zu nutzen
die rede ist hier von weiteren
technologien wie es uns menschen
ermöglichen könnten
aus der atmosphäre und dem reguliert des
mars wichtige rohstoffe wie eben
sauerstoff oder auch wasser zu erzeugen
in der fachsprache wird das all sin city
resource utilization bezeichnet
übersetzt also so viel wie die nutzung
der vor ort vorhandenen ressourcen auch
bei einer zukünftigen mondlandung könnte
das sehr interessant werden erst im
vergangenen jahr 2020 war es der
europäischen raumfahrt-agentur der asse
gelungen einen entscheidenden schritt in
richtung mondbasis zu gehen im
niederländischen noordwijk wurde der
prototyp einer lunaren sauerstoff fabrik
installiert eine anlage also die
sauerstoff aus mondgestein gewinnt bei
diesem verfahren wird der reguliert der
mondstaub zusammen mit einem salz
erhitzt und unter strom gesetzt dadurch
wird er in den mineralien gebundenen
sauerstoff frei und genau das brauchen
menschen die lange zeit auf dem mond
leben und arbeiten sollen
der sauerstoff der hier aus den
ressourcen vor ort gewonnen werden
könnte wäre auch in diesem fall nicht
nur super für die atmung der zukünftigen
mond bevölkerung es könnte sich auch für
die lokale herstellung von
raketentreibstoff eignen denn
trägerraketen wie die ariane 5
beispielsweise nutzen genau diese kommen
zion aus flüssigem wasserstoff und
sauerstoff ebenso wie die space shuttles
der nasa oder die saturn 5 bekannt von
den apollo-missionen möglicherweise
könnte der sauerstoff aber nicht nur aus
gebundenem wasser oder aus lunaren
wasser als gewonnen werden sondern eben
auch aus mode regolith es sieht also so
aus als wäre der schritt für uns
menschen zu einer multi planetaren
spezies wieder etwas nähergekommen und
wer weiß was danach passiert vermutlich
wird man dann irgendwann die ice monde
von jupiter und saturn an steuern auf
denen es sogar schon außerirdisches
leben geben könnte
apropos im neuen video auf meinem
channell geht es um eine spannende neue
entdeckung auf einem dieser ice monde
von saturn enceladus wenn ihr erfahren
wollt ob es dort im unterirdischen ozean
vielleicht alien leben gibt klickt auf
das angezeigte video ich freue mich
natürlich auch sehr wenn ihr meine astro
comics tv abonniert und mir hilft man
ziel von 60.000 abos zu knacken vielen
dank leute bleibt neugierig bis dann
bleibt dran